notre bien être notre qualité de vie et
dépend intimement de la qualité de
l'information que nous recevons
aujourd'hui je vais vous parler
d'information de qualité d'information
de transport collectif vous en doutez et
aussi de mobilité du futur
je vais à l'aide de deux exemples
essayer de démontrer de quelle façon la
maîtrise de l'information nous permet
d'avoir de meilleurs réseaux de
transports collectifs meilleure
performance des clients plus satisfaits
et ensuite je vais aborder la question
de la mobilité du futur
toujours dans une perspective de
maîtrise de l'information
maintenant si nous voulons regarder de
façon la plus simple ce qui est un
réseau de transport collectif un réseau
de transport collectif c'est un espace
temps où on a des gens qui veulent faire
un déplacement d'un point a à un point b
un moment donné dans la journée moi
comme opérateur ce que je dois faire
c'est organiser des rendez vous organisé
des rendez vous entre tous ses clients
et des autobus à l'avant nous organisons
ainsi environ 80000 rendez vous à chaque
jour maintenant je vais vous convie à
une petite expérience
je voudrais que vous fassiez vous
fassions ensemble un exercice de
visualisation j'aimerais que vous vous
imaginiez qu à tous les matins à 8h vous
prenez votre autobus j'aimerais
également que vous imaginiez que tous
les matins vous arrivée à 7h55 à votre
arrêt est qu à tous les matins où
presque tous les matins votre voisin s'y
trouvent
vous discutez avec lui et ensuite vous
prenez l'autobus maintenant j'aimerais
que vous vous imaginiez que vous avez
aujourd'hui un rendez vous extrêmement
important ce rendez-vous vous ne devez
pas le manquer et malheureusement vous
êtes un peu en retard
vous arrivez donc d'un pas pressé à
votre arrêt d'autobus et les 7h58
et là vous ne voyez pas votre voisin
vous êtes seul à l'arrêt alors qu'est ce
que vous vous dites
exactement vous vous dites gien de
manquer mon autobus 7h59 toujours pas
d'autobus votre respiration se fait un
peu plus lourde
votre rythme cardiaque augmente 8h
toujours pas d'autobus vos glandes
sudoripares entre en activité
8h01 toujours pas d'autobus et là vous
vous dites et que transports en commun
c'est donc pas fiable
8h02 pour d'autobus ne vous dit qu'est
ce que je peux faire
qu'est-ce que je peux faire pour réussir
arriver à leurs armes au rendez vous
est-ce que je peux appeler aux taxis
8h03 toujours pas d'autobus
vous êtes extrêmement mal vous passer un
mauvais moment 8h03 25 secondes
l'autobus tourner au coin de la rue 8h03
45 secondes vous embarquer notre bus
vous vous et soyez et vous ne serez pas
entendre
alors qu'est ce qu'il vient de se passer
il est ce pas ainsi que d'un côté on a
un client vous qui venez de passer un x1
mauvais très mauvais un très mauvais
moment et de l'autre côté vous avez mois
un opérateur qui est tout à fait
satisfait de sa performance puisque
moins de quatre minutes de retard dans
les conditions de circulation qu'on
connaît c'est tout à fait acceptable
donc qu'est ce que s'est passé donc je
vous ai invités à faire un peu de
risques de j ce que notre client vient
de vivre ce que vous venez de vivre
c'est une expérience aujourd'hui demain
que restera-t-il de cette expérience un
souvenir demain ne restera qu'un
souvenir les fai auront disparu et se
souvenait déterminera si oui ou non vous
allez faire une répétition de cette
expérience de si vous allez demeurer un
client du transport collectif
malheureusement le souvenir que qui vous
reste à passer à travers un puits sans
filtre qui s'appelle de filtres des
émotions
vous avez vécu une émotion négative
parce que l'incertitude génèrent des
émotions négatives
donc qu'est ce que je dois faire moi
comme transporteur pour réconcilier nos
deux visions moi je suis satisfait et
clients ne l'est pas je dois commun
absolument cette incertitude et c'est ce
que nous faisons et c'est ce que
l'industrie a fait l'industrie a
installé sur
l'ensemble des véhicules par exemple à
laval depuis maintenant cinq ou six ans
l'ensemble de notre stop et équipés de
gps
nous pouvons connaître à chaque seconde
la position de nos véhicules
nous pouvons transmettre cette
information là à la clientèle donc un
client ne plus jamais à s'inquiéter de
leur de passage de son véhicule
donc c'est une première utilisation de
la formation pour améliorer nos réseaux
vous amène maintenant de faire un
deuxième exemple nous avions un espace
temps avec deux joueurs nous avions les
clients nous avions aussi des autobus
maintenant nous avons un troisième
joueur nous pouvons introduire et ce
troisième joueur
ce sont les feux de circulation nous
devons synchronisée non pas seulement
l'arrivée des clients avec les autobus
mais nous devons également synchroniser
le passage des autobus au moment où le
feu est vert
donc ça fait beaucoup de synchronisation
affaire heureusement comme nous
connaissons la position des véhicules
chaque moment et comme nous connaissons
également la position des carrefours et
que ceux-ci ne bouge pas nous sommes
capables de faire parler les autobus
avec les feux de circulation de telle
sorte que le véhicule puisse commander
une priorité et avoir un maximum de
temps en faveur
si un autobus en plus en retard
naturellement il aura une plus grande
priorité et comme nous connaissons le
nombre de clients à chaque instant à
bord des véhicules
nous sommes en mesure de donner une plus
grande priorité un autobus qui aurait
plus de clients donc autobus qui aurait
cinq minutes de retard avoir une plus
grande priorité qu'un autobus qui en
avait deux un autobus qui aurait 43 aux
clients avoir une plus grande priorité
que notre but ce qui en aurait donc ses
deux deux innovations technologiques la
permettent d'augmenter significativement
la performance des réseaux et la qualité
de l'expérience vécue par le client
suite à l'introduction d'un système
stlsynchro la population par été
beaucoup plus satisfait de nos services
est ce ce ce dont je vous parle
présentement ça va être implanté au
courant de l'année à la fin de l'année
l'ensemble des carrefours à laval
vont être équipés de tels systèmes
maintenant nous sommes dans le présent
si nous regardons maintenant ce qui se
passe dans le futur
le futur est un peu plus complexe et la
plupart des gens qui essayent de prévoir
ce qui va se passer dans le futur
tôt ou tard finissent par avoir l'air
ridicule
je vais essayer d'éviter ce piège là en
me basant sur un certain nombre de faits
pour essayer d'imaginer ce que pourrait
être le futur du transport collectif
donc première série de faits nos routes
sont congestionnés nos villes sont
pollués 80 % des automobilistes roulent
seuls dans leur voiture et une voiture
95% du temps et immobile donc la
solution qui apparaît apparente pour
avoir un système qui soit durable dans
le futur mais c'est le partage
nous devons passer d'une économie de
possession à une économie d'usagé
deuxième constat l'ensemble des secteurs
d'activité économique subissent
présentement des transformations
extrêmement grande à cause de la
révolution numérique à cause des
plateformes collaboratives par exemple
qui aurait pu imaginer il ya quelques
années que le plus grand hôtellier au
monde n'aurait pas de chambres d'hôtel
que la plus grande compagnie de taxis
n'aurait pas de voiture ou que le plus
grands diffuseurs de films n'auraient
pas de salle de cinéma
pourtant c'est ce que nous verrons donc
qu'est-ce qui attend l'industrie de la
mobilité l'industrie du transport
collectif
on ne sait pas exactement ce qui nous
attend mais on sait que quelque chose
nous attend et on essaie de s'y préparer
on sait n'essaie de deviner ce qui va
s'en venir maintenant si je veux
représenter le futur je pourrais prendre
une perspective espace temps maintenant
multijoueur j'ai toujours les usagers
mes clients mes feux de circulation mais
autobus maintenant j'ajoute une couche
additionnel et cette couche additionnel
les composent et naturellement de nos
clients mais aussi d'un intégrateur un
intégrateur de mobilité comme nous avons
des intégrateurs de mobilité sur nos
téléphones intelligents
lorsque nous prenons des forceps
télécommunications cet intégrateur là
aura pour rôle d'assurer une
communication avec l'ensemble des agents
de la mobilité
c'est à dire que par exemple vous
pourrez prendre un forfait mensuel
un prix donné et ce forfait pourrait
vous donner par exemple droit lorsque
vous avez besoin de vous déplacer
1-1 véhicules en libre-service du type
de communauto ou de cartes ou go ou
d'autres entreprises du même genre il
pourrait également vous envoyer un
véhicule autonome les véhicules
autonomes
aujourd'hui sont quelque chose d'assez
peu comme on en voit dans les
universités on en voit dans les
aéroports dans des espaces très limité
mais on peut facilement imaginer que
dans cinq ou dix ans ils feront tout à
fait partie du paysage urbain
on pourrait aussi avec l'intégrateur
être mis en communication avec quelqu'un
qui veut faire du covoiturage le
covoiturage
maintenant avec des applications on est
capable de prendre l'ensemble des gens
qui veulent pour voitures et a comme
conducteur et l'ensemble des gens qui
veulent qu'on voit de sueur et comme
passager et des met en relation avec des
applications mobiles maintenant ces gens
là pourrait faire un premier segment de
cette façon là et ensuite avoir une
connexion un transfert avec un réseau de
transport collectif avec bixi ou avec
une citation prix et l'ensemble du
financement de la tarification de ce
système leur passerait par l'intégrateur
ce système leur n'existe pas encore
ce concept là existent en finlande par
exemple le concept existe et on a des
projets pilotes où on essaie d'implanter
certaines parties de cette structure à
laval nous travaillons nous
réfléchissons à la société de transport
pour essayer de faire masse la masse
c'est pour mobility as au service
c'est le nom de ce concept donc on veut
implanter ce type de choses là la vallée
on regarde comment on pourrait faire ça
avec un certain nombre d'acteurs donc ça
devrait être ça pourrait être ce qui va
ressembler à la mobilité de demain
maintenant trois choses à retenir la
première demain celui qui va contrôler
l'information
à voir également contrôler la mobilité
est présentement les gens qui veulent
contrôler l'information les gens qui
veulent se poser comme intégrateur ce
sont l'ensemble des grandes entreprises
informatiques ou du monde parce qu'il ya
une baisse de cela incroyable à faire
dans le futur
la deuxième chose qu'on peut retenir
préparez-vous usage devrait succéder à
la possession était troisième
demain la voiture intelligente roulera
sans compte twitter mais le conducteur
intelligent lui devrait rouler sans sa
voiture car ils devraient utiliser les
transports en commun merci